hello welcome back to gang Sports
coverage of e3 2016 I'm your host Daniel
Dwyer delighted to be joined by mr.
Michael Mojave and Damien Monier from CD
Projekt RED you're getting better right
every time
I'm determined not to get CD Projekt
people's names wrong pronunciation
imagine told yeah well I think I think I
was calling Macau Macau for a couple
years to me how me how me how getting
there and thank you everything for
coming on so I talked to album's leader
that's great look at that it even have a
lower third and the spikes ever been
fortunate because I had sway yeah it was
great to see the the side of the fig
being covered in in Gwent
it wasn't it hasn't been finished yes it
is right now okay really
right just in time thanks to our for for
your great unveiling here hunter games
my stage of Gwent of quiet it is a full
video game yes so before we get into
Gwen's can I ask you quickly
you actually made Gwent for The Witcher
3 right you were partly Tina did yeah
yeah I designed it with a mate of mine
and then once we had a prototype over a
weekend in post its right because we
didn't have long to come up with a
prototype then we enlisted some people
that had basically the spare time to
make it because we were very busy with
which right pretty big game but we knew
we wanted this thing and so we had Jason
who was our coder and some artists from
the marketing department so yeah there
was basically two of us working on it so
we I guess you know you took a dice
poker out of which ax - you were like
thinking of something else to put in
there yeah well we knew we wanted a a
card game because we like card games
yeah let's have a card game no time to
design it so we sort of out sourced some
ideas came back not quite what we wanted
so at that point adam Podolski who's the
studio director said look we're gonna
need to upgrade dice poker which was
still on and yeah a point I was in his
office and I said I'm sure we can do
better we can come up with a card game
in a weekend
Zach sure exactly I had no idea was just
so upset that we wasn't gonna get it
done it's all right let me do it for you
and he said fine it's Friday evening
come back on Monday morning exactly my
favor mate or like yeah sure no problem
and exit the office that were just like
in tears why we did it so we came up
with something the early prototype and
then yeah because we knew we literally
didn't have time so we made a better
prototype yeah and started playing went
against some people that we knew the
team needed and so coders and so on and
we said look do you like this do you
want this to be in which if so then we
Quentin needs you hit do work awesome
all night long basically for this and
you made it happen
we made it happen that's the thing when
always been really special for us
and then after releasing Walt hunt we
receive literally thousands of emails
and no exaggeration like thousands of
emails from fans saying a you know good
game how about standalone way yeah and
it was great I mean you had the physical
copy as well and the expansion pack as
well rest that was it though there was
the end we didn't think we weren't sure
that people were gonna like it that much
we liked it and then for the second
expansion is said okay we need more
quench I said okay I can make Skellig a
deck right
I had it prepared in my head in case and
we did it a bit or P but that was a way
for us you know what goodbye everyone we
know is the last one so here's an Opie
deck have fun with it and then the said
okay let's make a promise
yeah well Aaron's get a little bit of
restless here so I kind of want to get
the game started going alright with the
fat thumbs yes that works perfectly
actually made we made an eridan deck Oh
wonderful congratulation now we are
against northern realms as you can see
this point few things that change yes
you will approve because there but we
wanted to keep the core mechanic mmm
well for example 10 cards at the
beginning definitely redraw the yeah
nice one you got some wall hand riders
there now you can redraw up to three
actually okay
a few things this one is a cool car this
is one of the fans favorite can we have
a look at roach all wonderful roach
basically sitting up there you might
want to redraw her because Roach
actually comes on whenever a hero card
comes on the board
okay will come at a random point on the
board just like in which her yes so a
monster versus northern realms looking
at two different tactics I know you guys
are familiar with Gwen right but well a
lot of the people who are watching on
the stream I yeah it's that simple
you've got your army that will go on the
battlefield fight for you your army
being your deck being your hand you get
ten cards at the beginning and though
that's gonna remain your hand until the
end of the whole game so you have to
manage your units you have to know when
to bluff and the goal is basically to
have a higher value than your opponent I
think that's that in a nutshell
basically yeah one of the wonderful
things about this is you sort of you
know you have on your deck and that can
change obviously but you know there's an
element of like sometimes it's even
advantageous to sort of intentionally
lose one of the rams yes just so you can
make sure your the amount of times at
the start of thing grant that I was like
I won the first game and I was like yeah
four cards left a nightmare yeah we want
to make it as expensive for the opponent
as possible so right now I don't want to
say too much because we have someone
off-screen
playing right yes I don't want to say
what we have in a hand but I was
evidence French by the way if you didn't
know a Polly Polly before say I'm he's
not gonna is no he doesn't say anything
nods and chokes me why you guys doing
the hotel with us here
so there's also like a single-player
that's right so what we did is like I
said Gwen has been a special project
from the get-go and when we said okay
let's make it stand alone I stand alone
we basically said okay we're gonna do it
we're gonna do it properly
let's go speak to the lead writer all
right Jeff are you on board do you want
to help us go on some cool stories maybe
some stories they you hadn't had a
chance to tell Witcher and not
necessarily gerelds the stories you know
then we got
Mateusz to maskavich lead quest designer
that's how you say his name that's how
you say mask of its or something yeah I
fit with French accent it sounds better
but isn't so he and his team came up
with some pretty good quest I think for
The Witcher I'm a big fan of their works
do you play as Geralt in those are you
playing a suit right now you will do
stories not necessarily it's stories
from different point of views each
faction gets its own so epic ten hours
long
oh it's brilliant you get this beautiful
map that you can explore with your
character and basically every every
class you could say is resolved through
Quint
right so weight should be the way it
should be every that's how we do it at
work whenever someone's upset right and
so yeah you interact with things we
wanted some elements from The Witcher
that we loved not the fans loved so you
interact with something the way you
interact with it maybe like sale ruin
hmm you choose to explore it and it's
right with people or some way you may
get a card or a soldier that won't join
your army and then you carry on mmm you
might come across a village that's been
attacked by the wild hunt so you will
maybe start on round 2 with frost
already and some right you know it comes
a bit of a puzzle
your hand how do you beat the guy in say
X number of moves oh that's cool so I
guess you're sort of having fun with the
the balancing within those games we
wanted not just do a pause and multiply
we wanted to add this you have another
word for epic epic from one writer
party massive nuanced no that's your
insane thing let's say massive yeah
expansive get this negative expensive
single-player campaign marketing meat
why we keep you here like well that's
the thing I think I don't think I'm
alone in thinking I mean in retrospect I
know better but I don't think I was
alone in thinking that you were just
pulling went from the game and then
you're gonna release that as its own
standalone thing but then now you have
all these layers you have an actual
story to go along with it yeah we never
do the bare minimum yeah we've got every
better we've got a draw I know yeah you
guys give the expansions yes quite long
yeah yeah ridiculous they're working to
the bone over there in Warsaw we work
ourselves because we love it honestly I
know it sounds like I'm bullshitting but
they come we do it because mm you know
fans give us the energy to just keep
going it's like when it comes across in
the game so what's the word we're in the
draw at the moment this is the the final
random is around quite a few cards you
just play the Scorch a classic why would
you why look dude who made the game
pontificate to every later it's fine he
plays where is the guy off screen I mean
it's a pretty good move but you don't
Scotch broach
alright go on I mean try and wrap this
up see who's gonna win yeah I mean you
know for the riders everything's not
used to losing
I mean he's no losing to Geralt maybe
this isn't going too well maybe have a
look I don't know because you only have
units anyway pop the leader pops off
there you go Dex had roaches so yeah
these tags are sort of and again sorry I
don't like to lose when we do a live
thing nothing scripted these are though
I don't
I actually don't know where the other
guy has in his hand oh yeah the game
starts off still very approachable very
simple for people that I knew as well to
went but we worked really hard on the
the curve because originally Witcher 3
will not you know what let's just if
people find or buy cards right super
rupees does let them have a full hand of
hero cards yeah why because it's a
single-player garel at the end of which
were three Europe here and yes owning
the same word when just it was a does
I'm gonna feel powerful yeah yeah yes we
thought it was gay obviously now as the
multiplayer oh that's not good it's
gonna get upset so what's happened here
for the folks who don't all right so
what's happening is that it's 52 to 19
the opponents got no cards left and he's
leader to to use leader abilities sort
of this one-off ability you can use once
in a match and Aaron's got two cards as
well play them so work out what happens
go new spies we've got a new so price of
things that yes that is great we have
new spies spies are cards that allow you
to draw more cards from your deck
because obviously like we said we only
get ten cards at the beginning so those
cards are really reinforcing we've got
this
maybe you know 142 19 that's quite the
yeah that is yeah the guy off-screen
knows what he is doing and this card is
one of the one of the new spectacle
cards we have Waldman leader that you
know what you may as well rage quit rage
quit button yeah I've got to help him
because he doesn't know dog don't ruin I
said yeah you can forfeit in rage quit
I'm so sorry
sorry man such a good job I mean who was
it that bet you I mean it there's only
ever one person that's ever let's bring
that you at any one time bring him on
oh my history Geralt of Rivia
congratulations amazing yeah you need to
separate these two my sweater ok shake
your hand girls alright wonderful
alright thank you so much wine DJ from
said that project alright where's it out
I can't play it getting better
no thanks for having us you know we love
you guys in the office no worries making
people play it Gwen
oh sorry Wednesday night it's out in
September I got so excited Mike wankum
so it's out of September Xbox one and PC
fest and yeah please we need everybody
to join and destroy our servers we made
it for you guys so we need your feedback
like wait calm the carrots everything
dummy and thank you so much for coming
on we'll be back in a second as long as
our set is still here with our kingdom
come deliver and so stay stay around and
we'll be back hopefully in a minute
peace